good morning Hank it's Monday good
morning Hank mornin
Hank Hank you just got said hello to by
your cousin Teresa her husband George
world-famous author Lisa E and Arthur
Levine who edited the Harry Potter books
you heard me right
you just got said hello to by someone
who knows
JK Rowling Arthur's kind of a
nerdfighter maybe we can talk Joe into
being a nerdfighter I feel like we can
call her Joe because you know you got
said allo - bye Arthur Arthur knows Joe
so we kind of know Joe Haeg I have a
piece of good news and I have a piece of
bad news the bad news is that the Yeti
has absolutely vetoed the ex-girlfriend
punishment she feels like you know I've
tortured them enough with the radio
pieces and all of that stuff the good
news is that I think I have a suggestion
for a punishment that will be even
better but in order to find out if this
punishment is possible I need to call
Brotherhood 2.0 resident mathematician
Daniel Biss Daniel it's John Green I
have a question for you is it legal for
you to receive campaign contributions
from people who are sending you campaign
contributions because I am injuring
myself I have to do a punishment anyway
so I was thinking why don't I do a
punishment that decreases worldsuck yeah
but it's also maybe like waxing an
entire leg waxing your legs doesn't hurt
waxing your chin hurts girls wax their
legs all the time and they complain
about it but doesn't hurt that much
where they would stop doing it okay all
right sounds good I got to go I got to
go record the video blog this week we're
gonna be collecting donations to help
Daniel Biss become the first nerdfighter
ever elected to state Congress state of
Illinois is 49th and education funding
thank God for Mississippi and Daniel
wants to change that Illinois also
doesn't have any kind of state fuel
efficiency regulations and he wants to
change that too he wants to help the
environment and put more teachers and
librarians in schools so basically he
cares about the same stuff we care about
now the key to Daniels grassroots
campaign to become the next state
representative in Illinois is not the
size of donations it's the number of
donors so Hank I propose that we based
the severity of my punishment on the
number of people who donate to Daniels
campaign incidentally Hank you'll notice
that my punishment suggestions this time
tend
focus either on eating or on pain that's
because eating in pain are both funny
now I realize that embarrassment is also
funny but we've done embarrassment quite
a bit lately so Hank I propose the
following 10 tiered punishment system if
five people are fewer donate to Daniels
campaign via act blue I will eat six
saltines in one minute if up to ten
people donate to Daniels campaign then I
will lead 1,500 calories of the grossest
food available in my grocery store 25
people
I will eat six saltines in one minute
while doing the novelty dance of your
choice
35 people I will wax a limb of your
choosing 50 people I will wax a limb of
your choosing and I will lick a cat Hank
I know you're thinking you're thinking
that's not very hard well it's hard if
you live in Indianapolis and don't know
anyone who owns a cat 75 people I will
break the peeps eating world record
currently held by punk rock nerdfighter
Curt and I will wax a limb of your
choice a hundred people I will break the
peeps eating world record while waxing a
limb of your choice waxing a limb of
your choice is one of those phrases that
isn't dirty but sure seems dirty the
more you say it 200 people I will find a
cat lick it wax two limbs of your choice
while drinking a thoroughly blend Erised
happy meal from McDonald's 500 people I
will spend 16 hours straight without
paws inside the Walmart next to my house
5,000 people I'll get a nerdfighter
tattoo Hank if you were the nerdfighters
have more suggestions about punishments
I'm happy to tell you how many donors it
would take to make that happen and I'll
see you tomorrow
Hank I'd like to thank everyone at the
SCV WI for hosting this great conference
and also for putting me on that gigantic
video screen